Un de mes personnages de dessin animé préférée est Snoopy.
J'adore la façon qu'il a de rester assis dans son chenil et contemple les grandes choses de la vie.
Donc quand j'ai pensé à la compassion,
ma pensée est tout de suite allée vers une de ces scènes de dessin animé
où il est assis là, et il dit,
"Je comprend vraiment, et j'apprécie vraiment
comment on devrait aimer son voisin comme on s'aime soi-même.
Le seul problème c'est, que les gens d'à côté. Je ne peux pas les supporter."
Ceci, d'une certaine façon, est une des difficultés
de comment interpréter une vraiment bonne idée.
Je pense que nous tous, nous croyons en la compassion.
Si vous jetez un oeil à toutes les religions du monde, toutes les religions principales
vous trouverez à l'intérieur un peu d'enseignement concernant la compassion.
Donc dans le judaïsme, nous avons, de notre Torah,
que vous devriez aimer votre voisin comme vous vous aimez vous même.
Et dans les enseignements juifs, les enseignements des rabbins, nous avons Hillel,
qui enseignait que vous ne devriez pas faire à d'autres ce que vous ne voudriez pas qu'on vous fasse.
Et toutes les religions principales ont le même genre d'enseignement.
Et de nouveau, dans le Judaïsme,
nous avons un enseignement à propos de Dieu
qui est appelé l'être compatissant, Ha-rachaman.
Après tout, comment le monde pourrait-il exister sans que Dieu soit compatissant?
Et nous, comme enseigné par la Torah, que nous sommes faits à l'image de Dieu,
donc nous devons nous aussi être compatissants.
Mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire? Comment est-ce que ça impacte notre vie de tous les jours?
Parfois, bien sûr, être compatissant
peut produire des émotions à l'intérieur de nous qui sont très difficiles à contrôler.
J'ai moi-même été beaucoup de fois à un enterrement, ou l'ai présenté,
où quand je me suis assis avec les personnes endeuillées ou les personnes mourantes,
je suis submergée par la tristesse, par la difficulté,
la difficulté qui est là pour la famille, pour la personne.
Et je suis si touchée que j'en ai les larmes aux yeux.
Et maintenant, si je m'autorisais moi même à être submergée par ces sentiments,
je ne serais pas en train de faire mon boulot,
car je dois en réalité être là pour eux
et m'assurer que les rituels s'accomplissent, que les pratiques sont considérées.
Et par contre, d'un autre côté, si je ne ressentais pas cette compassion,
alors je pense qu'il serait temps pour moi de raccrocher ma robe
et renoncer à être un rabbin.
Et ces mêmes sentiments sont là pour nous tous qui sommes confrontés au monde.
Qui ne peut pas être touché par la compassion,
quand nous voyons les terribles horreurs de la guerre,
ou la famine, ou les tremblements de terre, ou les tsunamis?
Je connais des gens qui disent
"Bien, il y a simplement trop de choses qui se passent là bas, je ne peux rien faire.
Je ne vais même pas essayer."
Il y a certains employés d'oeuvre de bienfaisance qui appellent ça une fatigue de la compassion.
Il y en a d'autres qui ressentent qu'ils ne peuvent plus confronter la compassion,
donc ils éteignent la télévision et ne regardent plus.
Bien que dans le judaïsme, nous tendons à dire qu'il doit exister un juste milieu.
Vous devez, bien entendu, être au courant des besoins des autres,
mais vous devez être au courant d'une façon que vous puissiez continuer avec votre vie
et pouvoir aider les gens.
Donc une partie de la compassion doit être la compréhension de ce qui motive les gens.
Et, bien sûr, vous ne pouvez pas faire ça si vous ne vous comprenez pas vous même un peu plus.
Et il y a une charmante interprétation rabbinique sur le début de la création
qui dit que quand Dieu créa le monde,
Dieu pensa que la meilleure chose serait de créer un monde
seulement avec les attributs divins de la justice.
Parce que, après tout, Dieu est juste.
Par conséquent, il devrait y avoir de la justice partout dans le monde.
Et alors Dieu regarda dans le future du monde et réalisa
que si le monde était créé seulement avec la justice, le monde ne pourrait pas exister.
Donc, Dieu pensa, "Non, je vais créer le monde seulement avec la compassion."
Et alors Dieu regarda dans le future et réalisa que,
en fait, si le monde était simplement rempli de compassion,
il y aurait l'anarchie et le chaos.
Il doit y avoir des limites à toutes choses.
Les Rabbins décrivent ceci comme être un roi
qui a un magnifique, fragile bol en verre.
Si vous versez trop d'eau froide dedans, il va se briser.
Si vous versez de l'eau bouillante dedans, il va se briser.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire? Verser un peu des deux.
Donc Dieu mit ces deux possibilités dans le monde.
Il y a tout de même quelque chose de plus qui doit s'y trouver.
Et c'est la traduction des sentiments
que nous avons à propos de la compassion
dans un monde plus large, en mouvement.
Vous savez, comme Snoopy, nous ne pouvons pas rester sans rien faire
et avoir de bonnes pensées sur nos voisins.
Nous devons en fait faire quelque chose à ce propos.
Et donc, il y a aussi, dans le judaïsme, cette notion d'amour et de gentillesse
qui deviennent très importants. Chesed.
Toutes ces 3 choses doivent donc être combinées ensemble.
L'idée de justice, qui donne des limites à nos vies
et nous donne le sentiment de ce qui est juste à propos de la vie, ce qui est juste à propos de vivre,
qu'est-ce que nous devrions faire, justice sociale.
Il doit y avoir une volonté de faire des bonnes actions,
mais pas, évidemment, aux dépens de notre propre intégrité.
Vous savez, il n'y a aucune chance de pouvoir faire quelque chose pour quelqu'un,
si vous exagérez les choses.
Et les faire s'équilibrer toutes au milieu est cette notion de compassion.
Qui doit être là, si vous voulez, à nos racines.
Cette idée de compassion nous arrive
parce que nous sommes fait à l'image de Dieu.
Qui est, en fin de compte, l'être de compassion.
Qu'est-ce que cette compassion comporte?
Elle comporte la compréhension de la douleur de l'autre.
Mais même plus que ça,
ça veut dire de comprendre sa propre connexion à toute la création,
que comprendre cette partie principale de la création,
qu'il y a une unité qui sous-tend tout ce que nous voyons,
tout ce que nous entendons, tout ce que nous sentons.
J'appelle cette unité Dieu.
Et cette unité est quelque chose qui connecte toute la création.
Et, bien entendu, dans le monde moderne, avec le mouvement environnemental,
nous devenons toujours plus informés sur la connectivité des choses,
que quelque chose que je fais ici donne un impact en Afrique,
que si j'utilise trop de mon droit de carbone,
on dirait que, nous sommes en train de causer
une vraie pénurie de pluie en Afrique de l'est et central.
Donc il y a une connexion.
Et je dois comprendre que comme partie d'une partie de la création,
comme la partie de moi qui a été faite à l'image de Dieu.
Et je dois comprendre mes besoins
qui des fois doivent être sublimés pour le besoin des autres.
Cette affaire des 18 minutes, je la trouve plutôt fascinante.
Car dans le judaïsme, le mot, le nombre 18 en lettres hébreux,
représente la vie, le mot vie.
Donc, dans un sens, les 18 minutes me forcent à dire
dans la vie, voici ce qui est important en termes de compassion,
mais tout le reste aussi.
En réalité, 18 minutes c'est important.
Car à Pâques, quand nous devions manger du pain sans levain,
une demande aux rabbins de quelle est la différence entre une pâte qui devient pain,
et une pâte qui devient pain sans levain, matzah.
Et ils disent c'est 18 minutes.
Car c'est le temps qu'ils disent qu'il faut pour que la pâte devienne levain.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire, la pâte qui devient levain?
Ça veut dire qu'il se remplit d'air chaud.
Qu'est-ce que matzah? Qu'est ce que le pain sans levain? Vous ne comprenez pas.
Symboliquement, ce que les rabbins disent, c'est qu'à Pâques,
ce que nous devons faire c'est d'essayer de nous débarrasser de notre air chaud, notre fierté,
le sentiment que nous sommes la personne la plus importante du monde entier,
et que tout devrait graviter autour de nous.
Donc nous essayons de nous débarrasser de ça,
et en ce faisant, essayez de se débarrasser des habitudes, des émotions, des idées
qui nous asservissent, qui nous font fermer les yeux, qui nous donnent une vision en tunnel
pour que nous ne puissions pas voir les besoins des autres,
et nous libérez de cela.
Et ceci est la base pour avoir de la compassion,
pour comprendre notre place dans le monde.
Maintenant, il y a, dans le judaïsme, une merveilleuse histoire
d'un homme riche qui s’était un jour assis dans une synagogue.
Et, comme plein de gens, il était en train de piquer du nez pendant le sermon.
Et pendant qu'il piquait du nez, ils étaient en train de lire le livre du Leviticus dans la Torah.
Et ils disaient que dans l'ancien temps dans le temple de Jérusalem,
les prêtres avaient l'habitude d'avoir du pain,
qu'ils utilisaient pour le placer dans une table spéciale dans le temple de Jérusalem.
L'homme était endormi, mais il entendit les mots de pain, temple, Dieu, et il se réveilla.
Il se dit, "Dieu veut du pain. C'est ça. Dieu veut du pain. Je sais ce que Dieu veut."
Et il fonça à la maison. Et après le Sabbath, il fit 12 miches de pain,
les apporta à la synagogue, alla à l'intérieur de la synagogue,
ouvrit l'arche et dit. "Dieu, je ne sais pas pourquoi tu veux ce pain, mais le voici."
Et il le mit dans l'arche avec les parchemins de la Torah.
Et il rentra à la maison.
Le nettoyeur arriva à la synagogue.
"Oh mon Dieu, J'ai tellement de problèmes. J'ai des enfants à nourrir.
Ma femme est malade. Je n’ai pas d'argent. Qu'est-ce que je peux faire?"
Il va dans la synagogue. "Dieu est-ce que tu pourrais s'il te plait m'aider?
Ah, quelle senteur magnifique."
Il va vers l'arche. Il ouvre l'arche.
"Voilà du pain! Dieu, vous avez répondu à mon appel. Vous avez répondu à ma question."
Prends le pain et va à la maison.
Pendant ce temps, l'homme riche se dit,
"Je suis un idiot. Dieu veut du pain?
Dieu, celui qui règne sur l'univers entier, veut mon pain?"
Il fonce à la synagogue. "Je vais le retirer de l'arche avant que quelqu'un ne le trouve."
Il va à l'intérieur, et il n'y est pas.
Et il dit, "Dieu, vous le vouliez vraiment. Vous vouliez mon pain.
Semaine prochaine, avec des raisins."
Ceci continua pendant des années.
Chaque semaine, l'homme amena du pain avec du raisin,
et avec plein d'autres bonnes choses, les mises dans l'arche.
Chaque semaine, le nettoyeur vint. "Dieu vous avez répondu à mon appel de nouveau."
Prit le pain. Le ramena à la maison.
Cela continua jusqu'a ce qu'un nouveau rabbin arriva. Et les rabbins gâtent toujours les choses.
Le rabbin arriva et vu ce qui était en train de se passer.
Et il appela chacun des deux dans son bureau.
Et il dit, vous savez, "Voici ce qui est en train de se passer."
Et l'homme riche -- oh, mon dieu -- il en restait penaud.
"Vous voulez dire que Dieu ne voulait pas mon pain?"
Et l'homme pauvre dit, "Et vous voulez dire que Dieu n'a pas répondu à mon appel?"
Et le rabbin dit, "Vous m'avez mal compris."
"Vous n'avez vraiment rien compris," il dit.
"Bien sûr, ce que vous faites," il dit à l'homme riche,
"est de répondre à l'appel de Dieu que nous devons avoir de la compassion."
"Et Dieu," il dit à l'homme pauvre, "a répondu à votre appel
que les gens doivent avoir de la compassion et donner."
Il regarda l'homme riche. Il prit la main de l'homme riche et dit,
"Ne comprenez-vous pas?" il dit, "Ceci sont les mains de Dieu."
C'est comme ça que je le ressens,
que je peux seulement essayer me m'approcher de cette notion d'avoir de la compassion,
de comprendre qu'il y a une connectivité, qu'il y a une unité dans ce monde,
que je veux essayer de servir cette unité,
et que je veux essayer de le faire en comprenant, j'espère,
en essayant de comprendre quelque chose de la souffrance des autres,
mais comprendre qu'il y a des limites, que les personnes doivent porter la responsabilité
pour certains problèmes qui leurs arrivent,
et je dois comprendre qu'il y a des limites à mon énergie,
à la générosité que je peux donner.
Je dois les réévaluer,
essayer et séparer les choses matérielles
et mes émotions qui m'asservissent,
pour que je puisse voir le monde clairement.
Et alors je dois essayer de voir par quels moyens
je peux faire de ces mains les mains de Dieu.
Et par là essayer d'apporter de la compassion à ce monde.